THE GOOD OL DAYS:
Do you remember how it
was to buy a computer back in the early 2000s? For
the first day or two after buying a new computer,
we would spend all of our time setting it up.
We would install things like Microsoft Office,
Chrome, Adobe Flash, drivers, uTorrent, and maybe
a few games. We would also spend 3 hours waiting
for all of our files to transfer from our old hard
drive to our new hard drive. And who could forget
the countless restarts that we would have to
endure afer each and every install. But regardless
of how exactly this setup process looked for
you, one thing that we would all do to finish
the coronation of our new computers was install
Anti Virus protection software. We would use a
McAfee CD or Norton flash drive and enable our
1 year free trials that came with the computer.
We all felt that this was a necessary part of
not only keeping our data safe but keeping our
computers operational as fatal computer viruses
were a dime a dozen. After this initial setup,
we usually see McAfee or Norton every time
we boot up our computers, informing us that
they’re doing a malware scan to make sure our
computer is safe. And every couple of months,
we would get a pop up telling us that McAfee had
detected a trojan virus and that we can eliminate
the threat with just one click. As we clicked
eliminate threat on these pop ups, for a moment,
we would feel an overwhelming sense of relief
because from experience, we all knew how annoying
it was to deal with a virus. And this feeling
would make the $50 annual subscription more than
worth it. But, computers have come a long way
since then and anti virus software has become a
sort of relic of computer history. To be honest,
I’m not complaining because while I have some
fond memories of using Windows XP with McAfee, I
always hated McAfee. That crap made the computer
slow and laggy, and I’m glad we no longer have to
deal with anti virus software, but how could this
be. Every year, cyber crime is becoming a larger
and larger threat and the tech industry is pouring
increasingly large amounts into fighting against
hackers and criminals. Well, join me as we take a
look back how anti virus protection somehow lost
its place in our increasingly tech driven world.
MICROSOFT DROPS THE BALL:
Anti virus software has clearly
been left behind by the rapidly evolving tech
world. Someone else that’s being left behind
is the general public whose savings and income
are getting crushed by high inflation. And this
is where our bond investing platform Silo may
be able to help. With Silo, you can lend money
to the largest corporations and the US federal
government. And in return, they’ll pay you back
with historically high interest rates of currently
4-7%. Legendary investors like Warren Buffett are
well aware of this and that’s why they’ve been
buying hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
bonds. With Silo, you too can invest in bonds with
no markups and the peace of mind of $500,000 worth
of SIPC insurance and $2.5 million worth of FDIC
insurance. So, if you would like to stay one step
ahead of inflation and lock in high interest
rates for yourself, please consider checking
out Silo in the description below. But anyway, to
answer why we no longer use anti virus software,
we first have to address why we used to use
anti virus software. Normally, with these
types of things, there is no pinpointable factor.
Usually, it’s just poor security infrastructure
across the board that has gotten better over the
years. But, when it comes to computer viruses,
there actually is a guilty culprit and
that’s none other than Microsoft. You see,
Windows XP was fundamentally flawed when it
came to security. You know how sometimes you
go onto a sketchy website or an old website and
you get this warning. Your connection is not
private. Attackers might be trying to steal your
information. This warning basically describes the
entirety of Windows XP internet because Microsoft
basically botched how Windows XP communicated with
the internet. Now, I’m no cybersecurity expert
but from what I gather, the issue centers around
raw sockets. Whenever a file or piece of data is
sent over the internet, you have two main parts.
One is the actual file itself and the other is a
header that contains the meta data of the file.
For example, how big the file is. If raw sockets
are not enabled, this meta data is automatically
calculated based on the attributes of the file.
However, if raw sockets are enabled, like it was
with Windows XP, you have the ability to manually
define this meta data. In 99% of instances,
this doesn’t matter at all, but for someone with
malicious intent, this becomes free lunch. For
example, someone could misrepresent a 2 gb file as
a 2 mb file. If the computer knew the true size of
the file, maybe it would’ve stopped it due to its
abnormal size. But, since it doesn’t, this allows
random crap to be downloaded onto your computer
and that’s just a basic example. Essentially,
raw sockets allowed hackers to misrpresent data
that was being transferred over the internet to
Windows XP computers. Now, you might be inclined
to think that this was just an honest oversight.
Microsoft didn’t realize that people would use
raw sockets in this manner and that may have been
true. Maybe Microsoft didn’t realize it initially
but security experts like Steve Gibson were quick
to point it out even before the launch of XP. But
despite these warnings, Microsoft went ahead and
launched XP with raw sockets making the OS a
virus magnet. The shortcomings of XP, however,
were only half the story as Internet Explorer
was equally as guilty. If you’re familiar with
web development, you’ve probably heard of
HTML, CSS, and Javascript. These are the
fundamental pillars that make modern websites
functional. HTML gives structure to the page,
CSS gives design to the page, and Javascript gives
functionality to the page. But, internet explorer
could also run another programming language:
Visual Basic Script or VBS. At first glance, this
probably sounds like an advantage. IE supported
more languages making the browser more versatile.
This is probably what Microsoft thought as well,
but there was one major problem. VBS allowed
browsers to do tasks outside of the browser. This
was actually kind of what made VBS special in the
first place. Given that Windows applications and
system administration used VBS, a VBS script on
IE could be used to do general computer tasks. Of
course, this is great when used the right way but
when used the wrong way, well, this becomes really
dangerous. This is why it was so dangerous to open
unknown emails back in the day. Hackers would
name give files names like “Hello.txt.vbs” or
“Hello.docx.vbs”. These seem like harmless text
files but in reality, these files have to ability
to brick your computer, and that’s exactly what
happened to many unsuspecting users. And those
are just two of the biggest vulnerabilities
of early computers. Much of Microsoft’s early
software was plagued with such vulnerabilities
leading to the rise of anti virus software.
ANTI VIRUS PICKS UP THE SLACK:
To be honest, we can’t blame Microsoft too
much. Back in the late 90s and early 2000s, the
number one priority for Microsoft was to create
stable functional software. There was simply so
much to do here that they weren’t able to give
security the care that it really needed. And it
wasn’t until viruses started going rampant until
it really became clear how big of a shortfall
this really was. Fortunately though, we would
see anti virus software from companies like McAfee
and Norton pick up the slack, but what exactly did
such software even do? Well, from an overarching
perspective, the functionality of this anti virus
software was pretty straight forward. They would
basically just regularly scan all of the files on
your computer, identify sus files, and urge you to
delete them. The magic of this software was really
its identification algorithms which usually boiled
down to 3 main methods starting with signature
based detection. This is by far the most archaic
and least effective type of virus detection.
Basically, the virus detection software has a repo
of known computer viruses and references to how
their code looks. If the software detects that
one of your files has the same code, it’ll flag
it. This, however, only works with viruses that
have already been flagged and added to software’s
repo. So, it’s completely ineffective against
new viruses and old viruses who’s code has been
creatively rearranged. And this brings us into the
second type of virus detection: Heuristic-based
detection. This is basically an evolved version of
signature based detection. Instead of looking for
exact matches in code, this detection looks for
matches in functionality within a files code. This
should theoretically protect you against viruses
that use similar methods and exploits. But likely
the most effective type of virus detection is
behavior based detection. Instead of focusing
on the code, this type of detection focuses on
what computer files are actually doing. Is a file
randomly duplicating itself and destroying your
disk space? Is a file randomly trying to access
your system files? Is a file ranodmly trying to
corrupt stored data and so on and so forth? Aside
from these scans, anti virus software usually
also comes with some sort of firewall. This
might sound like some advanced security measure
but really, a firewall is just a gate between
your computer and the internet. Whenever you
download a file either knowingly or unknowingly,
the firewall will run these same sort of scans
on the file you wanna download and block them if
necessary. Hearing all this, you’re probably
thinking that all of this sounds a bit too
simplistic. Is that really all that anti virus
software was doing? Well, it’s obviously a
lot easier said than done but you’re not wrong.
Accomplishing the same tasks as these antivirus
software is not particularly hard especially
for a software giant like Microsoft, and that’s
precisely why they started addressing these issues
themselves. Starting from Windows 7, Microsoft
would start shipping their own Firewall with
Windows but the real jump forward didn’t happen
till Windows 8. This is quite ironic given that
Windows 8 is usually viewed in a super negative
light as Microsoft’s worst OS of all time, but
it turns out that Windows 8 actually made huge
leaps in terms of security. You see, Windows
8 came preinstalled with a tool called Windows
Defender which was basically just an out of the
box version of Microsoft’s anti virus software:
Microsoft Security Essentials. This made Windows 8
the first version of Windows to come preinstalled
with full anti virus protection software.
Windows 10 and eventually 11 built upon this
with auto updates and more security but no one
ever really gave this a second thought. Everyone
was too busy talking about the horrible Windows
8 tiles which to be honest I don’t think were
that bad. But over time, people did slowly notice
leading us to the death of anti virus protection.
THE DEATH OF VIRUS PROTECTION:
There was never really a pivotal
turning point when people just suddenly
ditched anti virus software. Rather,
it was much more of a gradual decline. You might
forget to renew your McAfee subscription one year,
and suddenly its been 6 months since you forgot
to renew. You realize that you didn’t have any
issues over the past 6 months and decide to just
not renew. General perception also plays a big
role in this. One of the main reasons that people
were so intent on buying anti virus protection
was because they were constantly hearing horror
stories from friends and family and the news.
Uncle Joe just happened to open an unsuspecting
email from what seemed like his son and boom,
his computer got fried. These are the types
of stories that drove people to buy anti virus
protection back in the day, but we rarely hear
about such stories nowadays. And one of the main
reasons for this is that all of us have become
way more tech savvy. We know when a download is
sketchy, we know not to open emails about Amazon
refunds, we know when a website is fake. Also,
even if we somehow do get a computer virus, we
all know how to restore our computers and get
all our data back from the cloud. This is really
just an inconvenience, not a game changer like it
used to be. Moreover, our internet usage
nowadays is far more curated. Virtually,
all of our internet traffic goes through Google,
Facebook, Amazon, Apple, and other reputable big
tech companies. This isn’t to say that there’s no
more fears regarding cybersecurity because there
absolutely is. However, the fears have morphed.
Nowadays, the concerns are keeping your data
private, using VPNs, keeping your identity
safe and so on. As such, the goal of hackers
has also morphed. Hackers are no longer trying to
brick your computer with a trojan virus. In fact,
that would be counterproductive as hackers want
you to use your computers for as long as possible
with no issues so that they can steal as much
data as possible. So, unfortunately, keeping
safe online is still very much a concern but
traditional anti virus software simply no longer
plays a big role in this and that’s what happened
to anti virus software. If you don’t wanna be left
behind like anti virus software, please consider
checking out Silo in the description below.